I'm Eric Haines and I'll be teaching about something I love, computer graphics.
What's not to like? In this area of computer science, you will write code to
create cool pictures. I've been programming computers since 1974 and I've been
working on computer graphics since 1983. With computer chips constantly getting
faster and with graphics accelerators, in particular evolving at a rapid clip,
the rules about what's possible change time and time again. There's always new
things to learn. I guarantee that the computer languages and hardware we will
use will change. The good news for you as a student is that I'm going to focus
on what makes computer graphics tick. The underlying principles I'll cover here
will give you a firm foundation in the field. I'm particularly excited that I'll
be able to teach this class now. A few years ago, such a class would have been
extremely difficult. With the rise of a web technology called WebGL, you can
simply click on a link and immediately run a 3D demo for yourself. In some
trivial sense, everything you see on your computer screen can be called computer
graphics. Word processors, videos, such as this one of me, paint programs, and
much else result in images on your monitor.